junge alter richtig
[Musik]
hey was geht ab jetzt willkommen bei
meinem ersten video im jahr 2018
wir haben schon den vierten jammer und
heute kommt gerade wenn mein erstes
video ja ich muss sagen mir persönlich
tut es auch ein bisschen leid dass bis
jetzt noch nichts kam aber ich muss
jetzt erst mal einen kleinen gang
zurückschalten eigentlich sollte dieses
video auch noch 2017 kommen weil ich
habe es euch eigentlich auch versprochen
nur ich bin dann auch mal ein bisschen
krank geworden und musste ich nach
berlin weil ich dieses jahr silvester in
berlin war auch echt cool ja dann habe
ich einfach leider überhaupt nicht
geschafft dieses video zu drehen ich
würde natürlich schon sehr gefragt ja
alex wann kommen endlich die gewinnspiel
auflösung kannst du das jetzt endlich
mal raus hauen eigentlich sollte ja mein
reichsten kommen hat nicht geklappt
deswegen gibt es natürlich heute
erstmals am anfang des videos ich habe
allerdings doch mega durch zufall
ich habe das irgendwie vor einem monat
über so mal bestellt einfach weil ich
das einfach mal zum gefunden habe und
zwar irgendwie so eine fünf kilogramm
süßigkeiten boxer sind irgendwelche
süßigkeiten drin ich habe dieses paket
auch total vergessen das kann für uns
nie an man kriegt dann halt nun mal
diesen post brief und dann kann man das
halt entweder bei einem nachbarn oder
bei der poststelle in der nähe abholen
und das war zum glück noch da das lag da
echt schon so zwei drei wochen rum
ja ich habe irgendwann mal gedacht
vielleicht kannst du das ja mal
gebrauchen und deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht wir machen jetzt erstmal die
gewünschte auflösung ganzen ruhe und
dann packe ich noch dieses ich muss mal
kurz gucken was genau das war also das
war ein 32 eur 5 kilogramm amazon
süßigkeiten überraschungspaket der ich
gerne süßigkeiten mal sehr gut
gebrauchen deswegen packen wir das
gleich mal raus ich bin gespannt was
drin ist keine ahnung aber jetzt habe
ich mich erst mal die gewinner
rausgesucht was ich noch dazu sagen muss
ich glaube auf meinem handy wurden acht
sachen verlost hätten das weib 80 euro
geschenkpaket also für 80 euro weit
sachen dann hatten wir einmal dass jay
die glätteisen dann hat mir noch einen
260 euro mac schminkt paket dann hatten
wir noch nie hieß dann hatten wir noch
die action cam dann hatten wir noch die
sofort kämen dann die playstation und
das einfach auf wobei ich ja gesagt habe
dass dieses
und die playstation gerne persönlich
vorbeibringen möchte und natürlich soll
es eigentlich auch eine überraschung
sein das heißt die gewinner werden in
diesem video jetzt noch nicht gesagt er
halte für die damit gemacht haben wenn
ihr glück habt stehe ich irgendwann
vielleicht vor eurer tür und ihr habt
das iphone da habe ich mir nämlich schon
ein ganzes verzwickten plan überlegt
also da gibt es halt ein separates extra
video zu ich könnte jetzt ihr die ganzen
kommentare ein die wirklich durch zufall
ausgewählt wurden so das erste war dass
zwei paket das viper kirch geht an
ich bin zu kurz ein johanns generis auch
wenn er geschrieben hat ich würde den
schuhen gerne haben da irgendwie kaputte
schuhe habe ich hoffe du kannst mit
klamotten auch was anfangen weil es
nicht tut mir natürlich leid aber ich
meine sachen sind schon cool es ist auch
gerade neue kollektion heraus gekommen
ist natürlich wie man in der
beschreibung verlinken jetzt fragt ihr
euch bestimmt ja nix wie kann ich dir
denn jetzt bescheid geben dass sich auch
die sachen bekomme ich habe hier meine
e-mail alex wie mail at web.de
wenn ihr das lest das ist eigentlich
auch wichtig für alle selbst für die die
jetzt nichts gewonnen habe an die
gewinner schreibt wir dort einfach eine
e mail hin und schickt mit dem
screenshot dass dieses profil wirklich
euer profil ist also einfach zum
beispiel von dem dashboard oder jetzt in
dem fall von johann du kannst mir auch
einfach ein personalausweis ich dann
sicher wie du heißt dann schickt die man
für eure adresse und dann bekommt ihr
das zugeschickt wenn es aber zum
beispiel der johann in den nächsten zehn
tagen mir keine mail schreibt dann ist
es natürlich wieder offen dann bekommt
das jemand anderes der aufnahme von mir
kontaktiert wird also wenn ihr den
johann kennt sagt johanna ich könnte
johann jetzt natürlich selber eine mail
schreiben über youtube und das problem
ist da schauen die meisten nicht rein
deswegen habe ich mir jetzt diesen weg
überlegt ich hoffe er ist relativ
einfach aber gut wir machen weiter und
zwar ging es dann weiter mit dem 260
euro mac paket mit der schminke und das
ganze geht an lynn marie ich hätte
gedacht dass es schlimmer wird für
diesen wunderbaren kommentar hat sogar
acht likes bekommst du das paket
herzlichen glückwunsch ich hoffe du
freust dich schreibt ja auch einfach
eine mail alex email.de dankeschön und
bekommt zum glätteisen das bekommt die
liebe lilly hier kurz eingeblendet
meinen reisen ist scheiße es wird nicht
richtig war und die beschichtung wer das
ab ich würde folgen das plätteisen
gewinnen will ihn ja herzlichen
glückwunsch an dieser stelle und tut mir
natürlich unfassbare leid dass beide
reisen schon die beschichtung abblättert
so der jesu geht an ivan parra und er
diese
kommentare geschrieben ich wünsche dir
alles gute mit dem schuh schild mm und
dann bekommst du auch den schul so
schnell es geht so dann machen wir ganz
schnell die action cam und die aktien
kamen geht an land laut lehrt
beschrieben bei mcdonald's willkommen
weil wir können als ihre bestellung
bitte ich einen action kämpfe und alex
wie bitte cool wenn du diese
bestellungen annehmen könnte dass cola
kommentar übrig sie action cam
herzlichen glückwunsch
ich hoffe du hast viel action damit so
das heißt das iphone und die playstation
stehen praktisch noch aus da ist doch
kein gewinner ermittelt und mir ist
wirklich gerade erst aufgefallen dass
ich glaube ich die polaroidkamera ich
habe absolut keinen überblick mehr weil
das schon auch jetzt einen monat her ist
ich habe glaube ich echt die
polaroidkamera vergessen die müssen wir
natürlich auch ausbauen also unter
diesem video verlose ich jetzt einfach
die polaroid kamera schaut ihren
kommentaren hättet ihr gerne die camp
dem video daumen nach oben und abonniert
einfach meinen channel und dann im
detail das war es aber wirklich genug
gelagert das video geht schon wieder
viel zu lange und ich wohne jetzt eben
das paket und dann schauen wir mal rein
was für fünf kilogramm süßigkeiten ich
den nächsten monat essen kann also also
hier haben wir das paket das wort
verschickt von fuchs ja ich habe gerade
das amt gemacht da sieht das glaube ich
ultra schwer ist das paket aber es ist
halt nur fünf kilo aber fünf kilo
süßigkeiten sind schon eine menge
deswegen ich bin mal gespannt ich weiß
gar nicht ob das aus deutschland kommt
aber ich glaube schon
vielleicht sind ja auch echt coole
sachen drin die man noch gar nicht so
kennt also ich bin gespannt
wir machen uns erstmal auf das ist gar
nicht so leicht wie man denkt natürlich
ist an dieser stelle auch einen link in
der beschreibung wo ich das paket
gekauft habt also so sieht von oben aus
die haben ja praktisch noch ein paket
drin also ein paket in dem paket ja ich
mache jetzt einfach mal aus hast du
übrigens fuß tor wenn ihr mich sponsern
volt mit süßigkeiten schreibt mir
einfach eine mail
ich bin dabei der haribo lakritz glaube
ich denke ich schon
haribo hat ihn schnell
ohne witz gibt es das im laden ich habe
das echte nie gesehen kennt ihr das
schreibt die kommentare
haribo milchbar kenne ich auch nicht
erfolgen so das wetter so dass kathrin
dann wieder diese kirschen oder die sind
auch geld das label akris keine ahnung
warum machen wir seit 21 richtig kennt
auch jeder nichts besonderes haribo de
salud blitz habe ich auch noch nie
gehört dass man sich auch probieren
schmecken ja die sind auch wenn es geld
ziemlich sauer aber schmecken gut
stellt euch das mal im haribo vulcano
fitz ohne spaß kein plan noch nie
gesehen wenn ihr das kennt schreibt es
in die kommentare
wir machen das jetzt mal alles gelaufen
so sieht das aushalten vulkan war mit
füllung gibt dann zum beispiel auch in
blau
da ist eine füllung drin so die ganz
normalen lakritz die kennt jeder
hier sind auch geldspenden ja
wahrscheinlich auch und dann gibt es
hier noch diese marshmallows oder so
schamlos und dann war auch dieses paket
da drin was jetzt hier drin ist
vielleicht schokolade
ich hoffe mal das ist ein bisschen
schokolade also die amag ist auch noch
mehr flächen so wir haben hier einmal
die passt das futter junge alter nicht
fertig andere wie arriva fantasia plus
20 grad
danke
und hier haribo fruit mail oder was ist
das denn
das ist echt geil das kenne ich auch
nicht aber ich will jetzt auch nicht auf
machen einfach weiter offen ist und ich
glaube dass ich das jetzt echt nicht mal
so eben schnell essen kann so und jetzt
passte auf schaut euch das an alter wir
haben hier moment 12 packungen
milka-schokolade 12 packung aber das
sind auf jeden fall mehr so standard
sachen also die kennt man eigentlich
alle weiße schokolade finde ich auch
richtig geil
und ja das war es dann auch
also insgesamt um die 25 sachen liegen
jetzt gesund also wenn ihr bock haben
auf süßigkeiten meldet euch bei mir ich
habe genug ja heute so viel erstmal dazu
ich hoffe natürlich die gewinner ihr
freut euch ich habe jetzt genug
süßigkeiten geiles video hab ich hier
wieder hingehauen ich muss jetzt erst
mal leider sagen ich muss wirklich eine
menge lernen jetzt im januar gibt es
nicht so viele videos ich versuche jede
woche 23 hin zu bekommen kann ich aber
nicht versprechen also drechslermeister
gemacht wenn ich bin weiterhin aktiv und
wir sehen uns dann wahrscheinlich morgen
übermorgen über beworben keine ahnung
hat rein